exotique se dit d'une plante originaire
d'une région du monde et qui a été
introduite par l'homme sur un autre
territoire
à la réunion on recense plus de 800
espèces exotiques dont le génial unis
fleurât plus connu sous le nom de
cerises côtelé originaire d'amérique du
sud
ce petit arbuste est connue pour ses
vertus thérapeutiques qui pressurise qui
s'est jamais goûté un petit cerise
qu'avec bien mais bien apprécié un petit
quiz à quoi laisser un petit peu de bois
qui sautent brésil l'a amené ça ici
parce que son petit tisane c'est pas que
de cerisy synonyme dicker de cerises
voilà nous qu'à ce petit coeur qui
tourne comme sa tisane de la fièvre
quand de mounana la fièvre jaune zoo ou
bien fièvre carrément un petit marmaille
c'est le coeur de cerises cup series
c'est la petite extrémité le petit
choeur carole da que les utiliser connu
et apprécié pour la fièvre s'est battu
pour la fièvre mais quatre cerise
utilisé aussi pour la dent les tisanes
de la grippe seront refroidis cement
avec peau d'orange cannelle et
les aussi avec
d'autres tisane comme bouasone ou
peut-être que mon peu de rayonner
icaunais alliés apprécié ali avec
citronnelle c'est à tisanes que de
mounana dans la cour qui plante et puis
qui vivent interdite et la case départ
en guillaume la banane pied n'a plus de
50 à 60 ans qui nous prenait frais
implanté et les parties depuis une
vingtaine d'années et le piémont qu'on
la mène donc aussi bien dans les op dans
les basses est un petit pays de bois qui
pousse et qui est très utile dans la cua
on a le choix soit nous mettre carrément
teese comme ça d'un grand bouteille et
puis nous mettre comme seule tige de
plantes lacets bois d'art dette que nous
met dans macération d'un bouteille ou
bien coupé coupé en petits morceaux
compagnie bonbons les connu pour ses
effets macération dans l'alcool pour les
douleurs pas confondre avec le branle
qu'on ne trouve plus souvent dans les
hautes de dalles et odile différence est
nette d'un branle blanc et le branle bas
les voilà donc pareil nous couper en
petits morceaux
tout ça dans un bouteille avec d'alcool
dedans nous choisit notre école du match
quand ils voient en a assez des plantes
dedans ilves l'alcool dans s'était à
nouveau mettre un peu d'alcool dedans
bien que oui à toutes les plantes
après booth et les saligues côté dance
d'un quoi ou ce qui fait chaud sur le
soleil puis nous retourne ali tous les
jours un petit peu pendant quinze jours
et donc un jour où les bons pour frotter
peu douleur de cerises de mon âme au
nifff les confitures avec la cerise
sinon les peut-être pas suffisamment
mise en valeur la réunion sa cseries du
brésil à tissot isaac au danois peau de
pêche n'est pas de pomme n'est pas tout
qualité fruits n'aurait pas de même des
cerises d'europe est un outil cerise la
cinu métayère valeurs me pense que l'une
a toute sa place dans nos qualités de
quantité de fruits que nous produisons à
la réunion c'est vrai qu'un petit peu
fragile mais c'est des petits fruits à
ramasser à consommer de suite dans la
cour déjà 2009 avoir un petit pied en
plus de tisanes donald aux fruits et le
picbois les jolies